kiev's maidan square
crucible of ukraine's people power
revolution
menace through the night
by the sound of constant gunfire and
explosions
[Applause]
the fighting is coming closer and closer
to the center
this is thought to have been filmed on
one of the main routes into the city
burning vehicles on paramahi or victory
avenue
across the capital the sound of
explosions through the night as
ukraine's president issued this call to
arms to his people
we will not lay down the weapons
we will defend our state
because our weapon is our truth
and the truth is that this is our land
our country our children
and we will defend all of that
more apocalyptic scenes sear the night
sky in the south of the country the city
of mikaelaev lit up by a huge fireball
russia's invasion of ukraine continues
relentlessly columns of armour streaming
through its highways
and with them reports of atrocities this
is reportedly an attack on a hospital in
malitopol
in kiev ukrainian forces are deploying
as the russians encircle their city
fighting in these residential areas
could lead to huge civilian loss of life
[Applause]
the mass exodus from the capital
continues people rushing to flee their
beleaguered city
seeking safety further west
scenes europe has witnessed for 80 years
played out as russia's unprovoked attack
on its neighbor continues without
restraint